Bonjour, c'est Cyprien
il y a quelques jours on m'a proposé d'aller faire du vélib dans Paris
moi faire du vélib,
non mais c'est un truc complétement naze le vélib
C'est un truc de Parisien ça, moi je suis un ....
...
... Moi je suis pas adepte du vélib
Jusqu'à que je tombe sur cette vidéo
...
Ah bah d'accord la je veux bien faire du vélib
Oui, OK... je suis même motivé
Sauf que encore faut il réussir à prendre un vélib
...
J’exagère à peine ...
On doit valider deux SMS
et une fois que t'as enfin ton vélib
tu peut utiliser cette magnifique invention de l'homme moderne
La piste cyclable
qui je le rappelle est utilisée par deux types de personnes
Les cyclistes
Et les gens qui marchent dessus,
Qui te fond c**** parce qu'ils rentrent dedans
POURQUOI il y a des gens qui marchent dessus
Pourtant c'est indiqué
A quoi pense les gens quand ils se promènent sur la piste cyclable
Elle est sympa cette petite allée
il y a personne dessus
Les gens son c*** de marcher à côté
Tiens c'est quoi ce logo
On dirait une b***
Il ne y a pas que les piétons que tu te prends sur la piste cyclable
Il y a aussi les voitures mal garées
et ce que je préfère c'est les autres cyclistes qui roulent en sens inverse
Oui parce qu'il y a des sens sur les pistes cyclables
c'est indiqué
C'est pareil à quoi pense les mecs à ce moment là ?
Ah elle est sympa cette piste cyclable
Tiens c'est quoi ce logo
Ils ont fait un cycliste à l’envers
Qu'ils sont c***
En plus on dirait une b***
En quand tu te prends pas,
des piétons,
des voitures
ou d'autres cyclistes dans la g*****
quand tu penses enfin être en sécurité
C'est la piste qui commence à te faire peur
A un moment j'ai du utiliser une piste
Je vous jure
qui passait entre
la voie des voitures
et la voie pour les bus
c'est à dire,
l’endroit le plus dangereux du monde
le mec qui a eu cette idée devait détester les cyclistes
Bon écoutez les mecs j'ai eu une idée
quand ont c'est plus ou mettre cette piste cyclable de m****
on la met
entre les bus
et les voitures
comme ça quand ces bleros de cyclistes vont éviter une voiture sur la gauche
ils se font écraser par un bus
alors?
c'est cadeau
arrêtez
Mais bon,
miracle je suis toujours en vie
les gens avec qui j'ai fait du vélib aussi
si vous faites du vélo,
avec quelqu'un qui va moins vite que vous,
Petit conseil...
mettez vous derrière
...
Aurélie?
je ne l'ai plus jamais revue
Continuez à rejoindre ma page facebook
Vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux
Même si je sais que la moité des gens sont des profils créé par ma mère pour me faire plaisir
arrête maman
Enfin non continue s’il te plait
et pendant que vous allez sur mon blog pour voir toutes mes autres vidéos
moi je vais m'assoir un peu apres une bonne journée de vélib avec une selle qui fait bien mal au c**
Sous-Titres : Ezio Cangialosi